DEGREES REVOKED.
>> Sean: TRACE GALLAGHER.
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
VOTED TO SUBPOENA THE FULL
MUELLER REPORT ALONG WITH THE
EVIDENCE.
DESPITE ITS FULL RELEASE BEING
AGAINST DOJ RULES THAT WERE
APPROVED BY THE DEMOCRATS
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T WANT THE OLD
LAW AND PLACE.
THE INVESTIGATIVE COUNCIL,
REMEMBER?
JOINING US NOW, DEVIN NUNES THE
FORM OF CHAIR AND THE OPPOSITION
MINORITY LEADER ON THE HOUSE
UNTIL COMMITTEE.
JIM JORDAN, THE INDEPENDENT
COUNSEL ROLE, LET'S SEE.
JERRY NADLER WAS AGAINST THE
REPORT IF I REMEMBER CORRECTLY.
I'M TRYING TO REMEMBER HERE.
HE WENT AFTER YOUR PARTNER TO
YOUR PARTNER DEVIN NUNES PRETTY
HARD BECAUSE HE WENT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
NOW I SEE THAT COWARDLY SHIP,
FOUR HOURS OF AIR TIME WILL COME
ON I WANT TO KNOW IF THEY EVER
WANTED TO CHANGE THE RULES AND
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL DOESN'T
HAVE TO RELEASE ANYTHING, DOES
HE?
>> NO HE DOESN'T BUT UNDERSTAND
THE SITUATION WE ARE IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE CHAIR
ADAM SCHIFF WANTS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO RELEASE
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION AND THE
JUDICIARY CHAIR JERRY NADLER
WANTS THEM TO RELEASE GRAND JURY
MATERIAL ON THAT IS WHERE WE ARE
RATS BECAUSE THEY ARE SO FOCUSED
ON GETTING THE PRESIDENT.
FORGET ABOUT THE LAW THAT THEY
HELPED CHANGE THE RULE OF LAW
AND HOW THINGS ARE SUPPOSED TO
HAPPEN.
THEY ARE ALL ABOUT GETTING THE
PRESIDENT AND THAT IS A SAD
STATE OF AFFAIRS.
>> Sean: YOU HAVE BEEN SAYING
THAT YOU HAVE CRIMINAL REFERRALS
COMING THIS WEEK OR NEXT WEEK.
I THINK IF WE EVER WANT TO
PREVENT THIS FROM HAPPENING
AGAIN TO ANY OTHER PRESIDENT,
THE ONLY WAY TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
IS ONE WAY.
FOLD THOSE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE?
HOW SOON?
HOW SERIOUS?
>> YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THE FBI AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WE ARE WORKING ON THE REFERRALS
AND THEY ARE GOING TO BE MANY OF
THEM.
HE WILL PROBABLY AT LEAST BE A
DOZEN IF NOT TWO DOZEN
INDIVIDUALS AND AS WE CONTINUE
TO GET MORE INFORMATION AND
BUILD THESE, WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYTHING IS FINISHED
BEFORE WE TURN THEM IN.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT YOU ARE
EXACTLY RIGHT.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO DEFINITELY
LIED AND MISLED CONGRESS.
IF THEY DON'T GO TO PRISON THEN
WE WILL HAVE A TWO-TIER JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IN THIS COUNTRY AND
IT IS NOT GOING TO BE GOOD.
>> Sean: I DON'T THINK A LOT
OF THIS HAS BEEN GOOD FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
DEMOCRATS PERFUMING AT YOU FOR
JEOPARDIZING SOURCES AND YOU
KNOW WHAT?
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID HE
WILL NOT REVEAL SOURCES OF
METHODS.
WOW.
ADAM SCHIFF ADAM NOWHERE, HE SAY
ADAM SCHIFF ADAM NOWHERE, HE SAS
ADAM SCHIFF ADAM NOWHERE, HE SAI
REALLY HAVE COLLUSION THIS TIME.
>> DON'T FORGET THAT WHEN WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GOT
FUSION GPS BANK RECORDS, THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN THAT RAN AND
GOT DIRT FROM RUSSIANS.
THE DEMOCRATS SAID YOU CAN'T DO
THIS.
WHEN WE WANTED TO GO OUT AND SAY
WE THINK THERE ARE TO MIKE IS
FAISAL ABUSE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED HERE, THEY OPPOSE
THAT.
THE HYPOCRISY HERE KNOWS NO
BOUNDS BUT WITH ALL THAT SAID
PEOPLE SHOULD BE VERY WEARY OF
ONLY RECEIVING WHAT I CALL THE
MUELLER DOSSIER.
PARTISANS WROTE THIS DOCUMENT.
I WANT ALL THE INFORMATION THAT
FED INTO THIS BECAUSE I AM SURE
LIKE AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT WE
HAVE DEALT WITH IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS THERE WILL PROBABLY BE A
LOT OF FAKE INNUENDO IN THE
DOSSIER.
>> Sean: I AM LOOKING FOR ONE
SENTENCE.
VERY QUICKLY WITHOUT CONSIDERING
WHETHER YOU CAN AND DIED A
SITTING THEY SAID, NO.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE INTENT.
IT HAS TO BE A CRIME.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
DONALD TRUMP SAID THIS IS A
WITCH HUNT OR FIRED JAMES COMEY.
DOUG COLLINS YOUR COLLEAGUE, THE
FREEDOM CAUCUS, HE HAS BEEN VERY
HELPFUL IN RELEASING THESE
CLOSED-DOOR TESTIMONIES.
WE ARE EXPECTING A CASCADE OF
NEW INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE ALL
TALKED ABOUT.
THREE OH TWO'S, THE
APPLICATIONS, WHAT ELSE DO WE
WANT AND WHAT WILL WE GET?
>> MICHAEL HOROWITZ AND HIS
REPORT SHOULD BE CUT AND THAT
SHOULD COME IN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS.
TO YOUR POINT AND IF WE WANT THE
TRUTH AND JERRY NADLER WANTS THE
TRUTH AND LOTS RELEASE THE
APPLICATION.
IF JERRY NADLER WANTS THE TRUTH
THEN: GLENDA SIMPSON PUT HIM
UNDER OATH AND SEE IF HE TAKES
THE FIFTH LIKE HE DID IN FRONT
COMMITTEE.
IF THEY WANT THE TRUTH, BRING IN
JOHN HUBERT AND SEE WHAT HE HAS
BEEN UP TO FOR TEN MONTHS.
FRANKLY IF THEY REALLY WANT THE
TRUTH AND THEY DON'T WANT TO
JEOPARDIZE THE MATERIAL, BRING
IN BOB MUELLER.
WE CAN ASK HIM ALL THE
QUESTIONS.
>> Sean: THE GRAND TOUR
INFORMATION IS A LEGAL!
>> THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
I THINK WE SHOULD JUST BRING IN
BOB MUELLER AND WE CAN ASK ALL
THE QUESTIONS WE NOT AND NOT
JEOPARDIZE THAT.
ANYTHING THEY WANT TO ASK THE
GUY WHO THEY SAID WOULD FIND
COLLUSION AND HE DIDN'T, IT WAS
NOT THERE EVEN THOUGH THERE WAS
MULTIPLE OPPORTUNITIES, BEFORE
IT WAS DANGLED AND THEY DIDN'T
TAKE IT.
BRING HIM IN.
>> Sean: YOUR COMMUNITY SAID
THE SAME THING.
NOW THE MOLAR REPORT, WHOEVER